good
afternoon I'm Matthew Spalding associate
vice president and Dean of educational
programs for Hillsdale College in
Washington DC welcome to the alen P
Kirby Center for constitutional studies
and citizenship uh as you all know
Hillsdale College is an independent
College uh founded in 1844 by men and
women believing that the diffusion of
learning would perpetuate civil and
religious liberty since then over 170
years we have rejected government
support but more important or more
directly for today's discussion we have
refused uh to recognize our students by
the color of their
skin uh we continue to do so Hillsdale
College historically was an abolitionist
College um sent many of its young men to
fight for the Union Army in the Civil
War as you came in today passing on the
right you might have noticed a picture
of Frederick Douglas he spoke twice on
Hillsdale campus and that picture the
most famous picture of Douglas the one
he carried on his calling card was taken
on Hillsdale College
campus uh we don't judge people by this
color of their skin and we haven't we
think it's a principle in a society
dedicated to the proposition that all
men are created
equal but here we are today talking
about race and recent events and law
enforcement confusions
tensions we have a wonderful speaker to
address that to here today and as always
as our tradition one of our students
currently on the program will'll
introduce our speaker uh Bailey Arling
house uh is from Missouri City Texas
where she is a major in political
economy in Spanish uh she interned last
summer in Nicaragua she's currently
interning at the Heritage Foundation
she's getting married this Summer and
graduating in December of 2015
Bailey good afternoon Jason Riley serves
on the editorial board at the The Wall
Street Journal where he writes on
politics economics education immigration
race among other subjects in addition he
serves as an official commentator for
the Fox News Channel he has previously
worked for USA Today and Buffalo News in
2008 Riley published let them in the
case for open borders which advocates
for a free market oriented US
immigration policy most recent ly he is
the author of please stop helping us how
liberals make it harder for blacks to
succeed which tracks government efforts
to help the black lower class Riley
challenges the notion that
well-intentioned welfare programs are
the answer receiving High Praise from
economists like Thomas
Soul he examines how the unintended
consequences of government programs are
holding black Americans
back Riley highlights the pitfalls of
minimum wage laws affirmative action in
higher education welfare and soft on
crime laws which imprison blacks in a
vicious cycle of
unemployment subpar education and
dangerous neighborhoods a graduate of
the State University of New York at
Buffalo he lives in New York City
currently with his wife and daughter
please join me in welcoming Mr Jason L
Riley thank you thank you thank
you so my first book was about
immigration and this one is about
race pick the easy subjects the ones
that bring us together as a country uh
but thank you for that for that
introduction and thank you for the
invitation to speak here this afternoon
um we're still in the first month of a
new year
and it's a very important year in the
Civil Rights history of this country
because 2015 marks the 50th
anniversary of the Voting Rights Act of
1965 what many consider Dr King's most
significant achievement uh last year we
celebrated the 50th anniversary of the
1964 Civil Rights Act which outlawed
discrimination based on race and gender
and religion and gave blacks access to
jobs and schools and public facilities
that previously had been closed off to
them but access to the voting booth
access to the
ballot was still of course a challenge
for blacks particularly in the
South President Lincoln said that we're
a government of the People by the people
for the people but that's only true if
all the people can register and vote uh
the ability to vote is what of course
protects all of the other freedoms that
we enjoy in this country it's how we
hold our elected officials accountable
and responsible for the decisions that
they make so after the Civil Rights Act
was passed Dr King pressed for voting
rights act as well and 50 years ago this
summer President Johnson signed it into
law and it's been a huge success you
might not know that listening to some
folks these days complaining about the
black franchise or pretending that it's
in Jeopardy but it has been
a huge success just to give you a sense
of how successful the Voting Rights Act
has been in
1964 the year before it passed fewer
than 7% of blacks in the state of
Mississippi were registered to vote the
lowest percentage in the
South by
1966 just one year after the Voting
Rights Act passed the black voter
registration rate in Mississippi had
climbed to 60%
the highest in the
south in Mississippi was no outlier in
Georgia it went from 19% to 51% over the
same period in fact in every Southern
State the gains Were Striking today
black voter registration in the South
where most blacks still live is higher
than it is in other parts of the
country and in 2012 the last
presidential election year the black
voter turnout rate in America was higher
than the white voter turnout R for the
first time in US
history that's how significant and how
successful the Voting Rights Act has
been along with the Civil Rights Act it
represented the culmination of a
modern-day civil rights movement and
what I wanted to spend a few minutes
talking about today is what has happened
in the wake of these civil rights
victories with respect to Black Culture
and black Behavior
Behavior what's risen from the ruins of
Jim Crow terms of policies aimed at
blacks in general and the black
underclass in
particular where's there been progress
where's there where's there been
retrogression what's working what's not
working and how much of what's not
working can be blamed on white
racism Tom Soul the black Economist at
Stanford and one of the people I
dedicated my book to once said that
some books you write for pleasure and
some you write out of a sense of Duty
because there are things that need to be
said and other people who have better
sense than to say
them this book falls into that latter
category for me when I started out as a
journalist 20 years ago I had no
expectation of focusing on Race related
topics per se people like soul and
Shelby steel and Walter Williams and a
few other independent black thinkers to
my mind at least least had already said
what needed to be said had been saying
it for decades and had been saying it
more eloquently than I ever could but
over the years and with some prodding
from those guys it occurred to me that
not enough younger blacks were following
in their footsteps it also occurred to
me that many of the public policies
aimed at the black underclass were just
as wrong-headed as they'd ever
been the fight wasn't over a new
generational black thinkers and writers
needed to explain what's working what
isn't and why to a new generation of
readers and the result is this book
which I hope will bring more light than
heat to the discussion of race now the
book is not an autobiography or a memoir
but I do tell a few stories about
growing up black and male in the inner
city one of the stories involves a trip
back home to Buffalo New York where I
was born and raised I was visiting my
older sister shortly after I'd begun
working
at the Wall Street Journal and I was
chatting with her daughter my niece who
was maybe in the second grade at the
time I was asking her about school her
favorite subjects that sort of thing
when she stopped
me and turned to me and said Uncle Jason
why you talk
white and she turned to her little
friend who was sitting there and said
don't my uncle sound white why are you
trying to sound so
smart and she was just teasing of course
and I smiled and they enjoyed a little
chuckle at my
expense but what she said really stayed
with
me you were two young black girls seven
or eight years old already linking
speech patterns to race and
intelligence they already had a rather
sophisticated awareness that as blacks
white- sounding speech was not only to
be avoided but mocked in the speech of
other
blacks now I shouldn't have been too
surprised by by this and I wasn't my
siblings along with countless other
black friends and relatives teased me
the same way when I was growing up and
other black professionals have told
similar
stories what I had forgotten is just how
early these attitudes take hold how soon
this counterproductive thinking and
behavior
begins New York city has the largest
school system in America and 80% of
black kids in New York City public
schools are perform forming below grade
level and a big part of the problem is a
black subculture that rejects attitudes
and
behaviors that are conducive to academic
success black kids read half as many
books and watch twice as much television
as their white peers for example in
other words a big part of the problem is
a culture that produces little black
girls and boys who are already worried
about acting and sounding white by the
time they in the second
grade another big part of the problem is
a reluctance to speak honestly about
these cultural
shortcomings many whites here being
called racist many blacks here being
called racial
traitors and many black leaders have a
vested interest in blaming black
problems primarily on white racism so
that is the narrative they push
regardless of the
reality racism has become an allpurpose
explanation for bad black outcomes be
they social or economic if you disagree
and you're white you're a bigot if you
disagree and are black you're a sellout
too often this is the level of discourse
schoolyard name calling ad hominum
attacks aimed at shutting down the
debate the shooting death of a young
black man by a white police officer in
Ferguson Missouri last year touched off
a national discussion about everything
except the aberant behavior of so many
young black men that results in such
frequent encounters with
police we talked about racial Prejudice
poverty unemployment profiling tensions
between law enforcement and poor black
communities and so forth rarely did you
hear any discussion of black crime
rates homicide is the leading cause of
death for young black men in the US and
around 90% of the perpetrators are also
black yet for months we had protesters
running around the country pretending
that our morgs are full of young black
men not because other blacks are
shooting them which is the norm but
because cops are shooting which is the
exception around 98% of black shooting
deaths do not involve the police
98% in fact in fact a cop is six times
more likely to be shot by someone black
than the
opposite the protesters were pushing a
false anti-cop narrative and everyone
from the president on down played
along any candid debate on race in the
criminal justice system in this country
would have to start with the fact that
blacks commit an astoundingly
disproportionate number of
crimes blacks constitute about 133% of
the population in the
US yet between 1976 and
2005 they committed more than half of
all murders in this
country an absolute
majority the Black arrest rate for most
offenses including robbery aggravated
assault property crimes even white
collar crimes is typically two to three
times their representation in the
population
so long as blacks are committing such an
outsize amount of crime young black men
will be viewed suspiciously by whites
and blacks alike and tensions between
the police and low-income black
neighborhoods will
persist the US criminal justice system
is a reflection of this reality not its
cause if we want to change the negative
perceptions of young black men we must
change the behavior that is driving
those
perceptions but pointing this out again
has become almost
taboo how can we even begin to address a
problem if we won't discuss it
honestly High rates of black violence in
the late 20th century are a matter of
historical fact not bigoted
imagination wrote Harvard Law Professor
William
stunts the trends reached their Peak not
in the land of Jim Crow but in the more
civilized North and not in the age of
segregation but in the decades that saw
the rise of civil rights for
African-Americans and of
African-American control of City
governments some people want to blame
these outcomes on racial animus and
poverty but back in the 1940s and 50s
when racial discrimination was rampant
and legal and black poverty was much
higher than today the black crime rate
was lower the black incarceration rate
was
lower someone to blame these outcomes on
the system or systemic racism but blacks
have long been part of running that
system currently that system is run by
one black man Eric Holder who reports to
another President
Obama black crime rates and
incarceration rates spiked in the 19 7s
and 80s in cities such as Cleveland
Detroit Philadelphia and Chicago under
black Mayors and black police Chiefs and
black council members and black school
superintendents some of the most violent
cities in the US today are run by black
people some insist that our jails and
prisons are teaming with young black men
due primarily to racist drug
laws but does the evidence support that
it's worth remembering that the harsher
penalties for crack cocaine offenses
that were passed in the 1980s were
supported by most of the Congressional
Black Caucus at the
time including by representative Charlie
Wrangle of
Harlem who back then headed the house
committee on narcotics abuse crack was
destroying black communities and many
black political leaders wanted dealers
to face longer harsher sens
in other words it was black legislators
in Washington who led the effort to
impose tougher drug laws a fact that is
often conveniently omitted by critics
to when these laws passed even the
opponents in Congress didn't claim that
they were
racist those charges came later as the
racial impact of these laws became
apparent but what's been lost in the
discussion is whether these laws leave
law-abiding blacks better off or worse
off do you make life harder or easier in
the ghetto when you send the thugs home
sooner rather than
later liberals would have us deny what
black ghetto residents know to be the
truth these communities aren't dangerous
because of racist cops or judges or
sentencing guidelines they're dangerous
mainly due to Black criminals praying on
black nor is this racial disparity in
prison inmates explained by the
enforcement of drug
laws blacks are about
37% of the state prison population and
state prisons house more than 80% of all
prisoners in the
country remove drug offenders from that
population in other words if you could
snap your fingers and send home everyone
who's locked up today on a drug offense
blacks would still constitute right
about 37% of all inmates
what drives black incarceration rates
are violent offenses not drug
offenses blacks commit violent crimes at
seven to 10 times the rate that whites
do the fact that their victims tend to
be of the same race suggests that young
black men in the ghetto live in danger
of being shot by each other not
cops nor is this a function of black
being picked on by cops who are overp
policing black
neighborhoods research has long shown
that the rate at which blacks are
arrested is nearly identical to the rate
at which Crime Victims identify their
asants as
black the police are in these
communities because that's where the 911
calls
originate if we want to help reverse
these crime
Trends we do better to Focus Less on
supposed racial animous and more on
attitudes in these communities towards
school work marriage child rearing and
so
forth but again this has become almost
taboo to say
aloud even when President Obama wants to
talk about the problems with the black
family and how that manifests itself in
criminal behavior and teen pregnancy and
so forth he gets slammed by black
Critics on the left who don't want him
talking about
stuff since becoming president both he
and the first lady on occasion have
spoken about these issues a couple years
ago he spoke at Morehouse a black
college in Atlanta and he said I was
raised by a heroic single mother and
wonderful grandparents who made
incredible sacrifices for me but I still
wish I had a father who was not only
present but involved and so my whole
life I've tried to be for sh and my
girls but my father wasn't for my mother
and
me I've tried to be a better father a
better husband a better
man he told those black men in the
audience to be good role models for
other less fortunate black men he said
the brothers who have been left behind
who haven't had the same opportunities
we have they need to hear from us we
need to be in the barber shops with them
at church with them helping pull them up
exposing them to new opportunities we
have to teach them what it means to be a
man now that might sound like common
sense to you and me in fact some people
in this room probably wish that's all
Obama would ever talk
about but he gets slammed he gets
heavily criticized by people on the left
when he says those things they accuse
him of being an elitist of condescending
talking down to other
and I'm convinced that's why he doesn't
do it more
often but Obama has the facts on his
side when he goes that
route is recently as the early
1960s two out of three black kids in
this country were raised in two parent
households today More than 70% are not
and in our inner cities it can be as
high as 80 or 90
0% for decades Studies have shown the
likelihood of teen pregnancy drug abuse
dropping out of school and many other
bad social outcomes increased
dramatically when fathers weren't
around one of the most comprehensive
studies ever done about this concluded
that black boys without a father were
68% more likely to be incarcerated than
those with a
father the study said that overall the
most most critical Factor affecting the
prospect that a male youth will
encounter the criminal justice system is
the presence of a father in the home all
other factors including family income
are much less
important the political scientist James
Q Wilson put it this way he said if
crime is to a significant degree caused
by weak character if weak character is
more likely among children of unmarried
mothers if there are no fathers who will
help raise their children acquire jobs
and protect their neighborhoods if boys
become young men with no preparation for
work if School achievement is regarded
as a sign of having sold out if all
these things are true then the chances
of reducing the crime rate among y
low-income blacks anytime soon is
Slim many people sincerely want to help
the black
underclass the problem is that they
believe bigger more expansive government
is the best way to do
that but having looked at the track
record of government policies aimed at
helping the black underclass I'm very
skeptical this year also marks the 50th
anniversary of President Johnson's
famous speech at Howard University where
he launched the Great Society
programs Johnson had just signed the
Civil Rights Act a year earlier he would
sign the Voting Rights Act in a couple
months and he used the speech at Howard
to talk about what the government should
do next on behalf of blacks this was
merely the end of the beginning he said
quoting Church Hill and then he said
that beginning is freedom and the
barriers to that freedom are tumbling
down freedom is the right to share share
fully and equally in American society to
vote to hold a job to enter a public
place to go to school said Johnson but
freedom is not enough
he you do not take a person who for
years has been hobbled by chains and
liberate him bring him up to the
starting line of a race and say you are
free to compete with all the
others and think and still believe that
you have been completely fair to that
person Johnson said that the next and
more profound stage of the battle for
civil rights was not just equality as a
right and a
theory but equality is a fact and
equality as a
result but what if Johnson was
mistaken what if there are limits to
what government can do Beyond removing
barriers to
Freedom what if the best that we can
hope for from our elected officials are
policies that promote equal
opportunity would if public policy
makers risk creating more problems and
more barriers to progress when the goal
is equal outcome
in 1988 right around the 25th
anniversary of the Great Society Nathan
Glazer the Harvard sociologist published
a book called the limits of social
policy the Glazer was analyzing the
Great Society programs from the
perspective of someone who in fact
believed the government action was the
best way to improve the lot of blacks
but his assessment humbled him he said
that government programs aren't the
solution to many of these problems he
said in many ways the Great Society
programs were causing just as many
problems as they were solving he said
good intentions aren't
enough but unlike Glazer many public
policy makers today are still riding
high on those good
intentions they don't seem particularly
interested in reconsidering what has
been tried even though 50 years into the
war on poverty the picture is not
pretty while gains have been made
significant racial disparities remain in
some areas and black retrogression has
occurred in others the black white
poverty Gap has widened over the past
decade and black poverty is no longer
falling the black white disparity and
incarceration rates today is larger than
it was in
1960 and black unemployment has on
average been double that of whites for
years confronted with these statistics
itics some continue to push for the same
solutions that clearly have not worked
President Obama announced yet had
another Federal initiative aimed at
helping blacks last year he called for
more preschool education even though
studies including those released by his
own Administration have shown no
significant impacts in education from
these programs he said he wants to
increase reading proficiency and
graduation rates for minority students
yet he opposes School vouchers that are
doing both
he wants to raise the minimum wage even
though there's long been strong
correlations between higher minimum
wages and higher black unemployment for
the president and many who think like
him empirical data seem to take a
backseat to Good
Intentions as one Urban policy scholar
Fred seagull has noted this aversion to
evidence on the left began in the
1960s the political left racked by guilt
over America's diabolical treatment of
blacks decided to hold them to different
standards of behavior blacks were
invited to enter the larger society on
their own terms right
seagull the same schools that had help
poor whites ceased incorporating poor
blacks from the south into the
mainstream discipline as a prerequisite
for adult success fell out of fashion
when it came to what whites expected of
blacks liberals tried to improve
conditions for blacks without passing
judge judgment on antisocial black
cultural traits and this sort of
thinking continues to this
day Walter Williams a black Economist
once wrote that he's glad he grew up in
the 40s and 50s before it became
fashionable for white people to like
black
people he says he received a more honest
assessment of his strengths and
weaknesses than black kids today are
likely to receive from White teachers
and employers
who are more interested in being
politically
correct after George Zimmerman was
acquitted in the shooting death of
Trayvon Martin President Obama explained
the black response to the verdict this
way they understand said the president
referring to blacks that some of the
violence that takes place in poor black
neighborhoods around the country is born
out of a very violent past in this
country and that the poverty and
dysfunction that we see in these
communities
can be traced to a very difficult
history in other words Obama was doing
exactly what liberalism has been
conditioning blacks to do since the
1960s which is to blame black pathology
on the legacy of slavery and Jim
Crow But ultimately this is a
Dodge those legacies are not holding
down blacks half as much as the legacy
of efforts to help blacks
this sentimental support has turned
underprivileged blacks into play things
for intellectuals and politicians who
care much more about clearing their
conscience or getting
reelected than they do in advocating
behaviors and attitudes that have
allowed other groups in this country to
get ahead meanwhile the Civil Rights
industry the Civil Rights Movement I
should say has become an industry
an industry that does little more than
monetize white
guilt Martin Luther King and his
contemporaries demanded self-improvement
despite the Abundant and overt racism of
their day King once told a congregation
do you know that Negroes are 10% of the
population of St Louis and are
responsible for 58% of its
crimes we've got to face that and we've
got to do something about our moral
standards King said we know that there
are many things wrong in the white in
the white world but there are many
things wrong in the black world too we
can't keep on blaming the white man
there are things that we must do for
ourselves I use those statements from
King in an article I once wrote for the
Wall Street
Journal and some readers wrote in
accusing me of making up a
quote which comes from a profile of King
that appeared in the 1961 issue of
Harper's
magazine I was a little taken aback by
the accusation and not just because the
Harper's piece can be located and read
without too much difficulty via
Google but what really struck me about
the
accusation is that those making it
apparently just couldn't believe that
the nation's most prominent civil rights
leaders used to speak this way about
problems in the black community and the
role of personal
responsibility which might tell you all
you need to know about the quality of
what passes for black leadership
today King
successors living in an era when public
policy bends over backwards to
accommodate blacks nevertheless insist
that blacks cannot be held responsible
for their plight so long as racial
Prejudice still exists in this country
but the more fundamental problem with
these well-meaning efforts to help
blacks is that they have succeeded
tragically in convincing blacks to see
themselves first and foremost as
victims today there is no greater
impediment to Black advancement than the
self-pitying mindset that permeates the
black subculture white liberals think
they are helping blacks by romanticizing
bad behavior and black Liberals are all
too happy to hustle these guil
whites blacks ultimately must help
themselves they must develop the same
attitudes and behaviors and habits that
other groups had to develop in America
in order to rise and to the extent that
a social policy or a government program
however well-intentioned
interferes with this
self-development it's doing more harm
than
good this concept of self-help and
self-development is something that black
leaders once understood All Too Well in
America and at a time when blacks faced
infinitely more obstacles than they face
today Frederick Douglas in
1865 said that everyone had asked him
and the other abolitionist what to do
with blacks after the
war he said I've had one answer from the
start do nothing with
us he said you've already played enough
Mischief with us if the apples will not
remain on the tree of Their Own Strength
let them
fall and if the Negro cannot stand on
his own legs let him fall
also all I ask is that you give him a
chance to stand on his two
legs the rest is up to
us Douglas was essentially saying give
blacks equal
opportunity and then leave us
alone decades later Booker T Washington
would share that senent he said that it
is important and right that all the
Privileges of the law be ours but it's
vastly more important that we be
prepared for the exercise of these
privileges once we have
them Douglas and Washington didn't play
down the need for the government to
secure equal rights for blacks and both
were optimistic that blacks would get
equal rights eventually although neither
man lived to see that
day but both men also understood the
limits of government benevolence blacks
would have to ready themselves to meet
the far bigger challenge of being in a
position to take advantage of
opportunities once equal rights had been
secured this Remains the challenge
today the
history of 1960s liberal social policies
in my view is largely a history of
ignoring that wisdom thank
you
okay we have some time for questions you
use we have
microphon thank you for a masterful
fullsome presentation that's almost
breathtak
thank you and especially from a fellow
buffalonian nice to have a
reunion if any of us in this
room who are are more glowing in our
appearance took that Podium and
delivered the same
speech how do you think it would be
received if we Chang the pronoun from we
to
you is that a factor uh who is
addressing the issue oh yeah it is a
factor but the audience is also
important I think if you
um you know I I've given the speech in
front of black audiences um and white
audiences and next um so um you know who
you're talking to matters a lot as well
but yes unfortunately it does still
matter who's making the argument certain
individuals have more credibility with
certain audiences so
yeah yes and I Echo the previous uh
questioners uh comments about your
remarks uh but question about the year
of speaking to uh black
audiences um how often have you been
invited or been able to appear before a
black let's say a congregation or what
have you and um how have your remarks
been
received
um they're generally re I spoke black
college earlier this week and they're
generally received uh well uh you
um again it
depends it depends on on the black
audience too if if you're speaking to uh
a more political group that is
um uh a group that has aligned itself
with the traditional black
leadership groups like the NAACP or
Sharpton's group or the National Urban
League groups like that you're going to
get a different a different response
you're going to get the same response
that Obama gets when he starts talking
this way in front of black audiences um
you'll get denounced um but when you
talk to the black Rank and
file um you get a completely different
completely different response I I think
um uh one of the reasons I wrote the
book is to sort of give voice to this
perspective in the black community it's
out there you just
don't hear about it a lot or hear from
them a lot because the the the the
traditional media continues to go to the
same folks to speak on behalf of blacks
so every time something happens they run
to Sharpton or they run to Jesse Jackson
they run to NAACP to get the black
Viewpoint and um of course those groups
have their own agenda which they proceed
to push um but there are um uh there are
more conservative viewpoints within the
black community then you you might
realize uh it's just hard to get at them
and one of the reasons I wrote the book
was to give
voice thank you so uh two common uh
challenges to that Viewpoint from the
liberal perspective is one when we cite
statistics saying 2 2 pound households
in the black community employment rates
were lower before the Civil Rights era
the common respon the common response is
well would you like us to take us back
before the Civil Rights era and then the
second response from the liberal side is
Barry Goldwater the father of modern
conservatism he voted against the 64
Civil Rights Act how do we respond to
those arguments because the liberal
point of view consistently reverts back
to those two points when they challenge
the conservative perspective on these
issues well
um I'm glad the Civil Rights Act and the
Voting Rights Act passed um I think they
made the country more just for everyone
the before before and after
comparison uh that I make is solely for
the purpose of pushing Back Against
Racism as an all-purpose explanation I I
don't think you can plausibly argue that
there was less racism in the 40s and 50s
than there is with a twice elected black
president in the white house um yet if
you go back to the 40s and 50s you see
lower unemployment rates higher black
labor participation rates lower black
crime rates um and so forth uh so that
that's why I make make that distinction
in terms of Barry
Goldwater I will say this although I'm
glad the Civil Rights Act
passed what he feared would
happen has happen where a law that was
intended to um produce equal opportunity
has been morphed by the courts into a
law mandating equal outcomes and
moreover in the absence of equal out
comes identifying that as racism uh he
was right about that happening um I
think some lawmakers at the time tried
to assure that it wasn't and in fact the
letter of the statute says that can't be
the case but that but that has
happened thank you for speaking with us
today um I appreciate your exhortation
that the black communities must help
themselves with a particular focus on
changing attitudes and instilling good
character from the fathers into their
children I I'm curious as
to your perspective on the role of
public policy and crafting incentives
which shape that behavior particularly
as it relates to um the father and and
looking at child protective or child
welfare programs like afdc tanif um how
can we shape policy better um such that
we would create better incentives for
black families to be stronger well
I guess i' the short answer is the title
of the book please stop helping I don't
it's not uh what I think it's not about
what I think the government should be
doing that it's not doing what it's
doing that it should stop doing um uh
open-ended welfare policies do not help
a group develop a work ethic which is
ultimately what they're going to need
develop Le poverty um trapping kids in
failing schools not giving them access
to better school school choice is not
going to help them uh receive a decent
education so it's it's it's uh
pricing poor less skilled blacks out of
the labor force with minimum wage loss
does not help so it's largely about what
um in terms of government policy we need
to stop doing uh uh one of the points I
make in the book is that um you know
these these Solutions are not going to
come from Washington they're not going
to come from from politicians even black
politicians I say know black man in the
White House is all well and good it's no
substitute for a black man in the
home
um so it's it's really about uh when it
comes to public policy uh get out of the
way stop doing things that we know don't
work um the problem of course is that um
there there there's a a whole industry a
whole constituency around these various
programs so
um in the school situation for instance
you have
uh kids are trapped in failing schools
that won't close because on the left
public education is a jobs program for
adults those schools stay open because
those schools are jobs whether or not
the kids are learning is a secondary
concern uh and so you you have example
of you have uh the same situation in uh
with respect to um
uh getting at black unemployment in in
some parts of New York some poor areas
of New York Walmart's been trying to
build a store for
years um labor does not like Walmart
because it won't organize its workers um
and the black politicians aside with
labor
leaders so here you have a situation a
neighborhood needs the jobs needs a
store with low pric goods and services
yet it's surrounded by individuals be
they labor leaders or the black
politicians aligned with them and taking
money from them who would rather the
people in that Community stay unemployed
than work at a
Walmart I mean that's those are the
barriers you're you're trying to clear
here when it comes to addressing some of
these
problems
y I just want to thank you so
much uh you're right on point uh I've
had
practical experience uh back in the
1990s was able to work with the
70 uh young black gentlemen that grew up
in Southeast DC from single parent homes
was able to train them in sales got more
success we became the number one
dealership in the Washington
area but it was just about that
opportunity is so important and the
liberal agenda has been
flawed all the way going back to LBJ
and lbj's
intent was to defraud the
black from their opportunity that
everybody else
received and then now we have open
borders this is again another problem
because blacks are looked down
to and this is just not
right we need to turn that around we
need a liberal agenda to get out of the
way and let free market capitalism
provide those
opportunities because I've seen so much
growth we don't need to give anybody a
handout yeah they might need to have
somebody handouts in trouble at that
time but don't limit them for the rest
of their lives don't ruin their
opportunity so I find your points
just we just need the right leadership
out there
to help people to get on the right
Road you know it's not about
education it's about
opportunity thank you Mr Riley uh
Charles Murray found in his coming apart
pretty much the same indicators for poor
white families and in in essence blamed
the welfare state as being fundamentally
responsible ible for the uh decline of
family life and and incarceration rates
um if one if one then broadens it isn't
it the same issue for poor whites isn't
it the same issue AC for in fact not
only poor but not so poor isn't it
really an encroachment of the welfare
state to two greater level and
disincentivizing just basic family
decisions and personal responsibility I
don't want to make it but so isn't
doesn't don't your points really apply
to that everybody in the country you you
could certainly broaden uh the arguments
particularly with regard to the
disincentives put in place by the
welfare state certainly um I think um uh
the one black white difference is the
starting point uh how bad things have
gotten in the black community um the
whites aren't quite there yet um so so
there there is still some distinction
there but I I think yeah the the broader
point is well taken um an overly
generous welfare state is going to have
disincentives across the board
regardless of race
ethics oh I'm sorry yes that it's lovely
Jason thank you uh it curs me while you
were given that fine talk um the the
black community has enjoyed the
administrations of the bureaucratic
State more intensely than anybody maybe
and for a long time and I wonder what
you'd say about their opinions and what
they hope for and whether Tim Scott uh
let's say he becomes a national
politician and
talks equal opportunity the way you
do uh that are they likely to respond to
that and it and it it I think it's an
important question because in a
way they're kind of a model on whether
the country can turn back from what it's
done and if they can everybody can and
so I'd like you to comment on that well
um I think I'll take a lot of Tim
Scots frankly uh I I I think the
uh uh the blacks have been loyal to the
Democrats uh for so long for a number of
reasons
um one is
uh
the history of the civil rights movement
and which side conservatism was on
someone mentioned Barry Coldwater
earlier um there are blacks of an
certain age who remember that era and
they will never vote
Republican GOP is lost to them
um but you also have uh uh what the what
the left is offered in terms of goodies
big government uh has been sold to
something that is good for you we're the
we're the party that gives you things um
whether it's uh jobs uh you see over
represent over an over representation of
blacks and uh government jobs be it the
military be at the post office civil
service jobs and so
forth
yeah and so you have that but also in
terms of handouts food stamps welfare
benefits and so forth so you see an over
representation there but I I think the
um going
forward the bigger
reason uh is the lack of concerted GOP
Outreach to the black
community the Democrats show
up and that's that goes a long way um
Republicans by and large write off the
black vote they don't need it to win
they know that time spent courting one
group is time not SP accoring another
group where you're likely to get a
bigger return on your investment of time
I'm not ascribing racial animous to it
it's pragmatic politics there just is
not a whole lot of black GOP Outreach
going on right now um a nice contrast
would be with Hispanics there's a huge
debate in the GOP right now about
whether they can continue to win
elections going forward without more
Hispanic voters so you see this debate
over how best to go there's no debate
over the black vote in the go and
probably to the extent that the GOP is
successful with
Hispanics it'll mean they won't me it
it'll mean they can go even longer
without needing blacks to win votes so I
don't think you're going to see a
concerted effort at black Outreach until
the GOP feels it needs these votes to
win and right now the reality is that
they don't and I think that largely
explains why you don't see more uh black
Outreach um and why you don't see more
blacks um voting Republican and you know
I'd like to see more of it and I think
it does pay off when you take a
politician um um over the years various
polit Republican politicians have done
this you can go back to uh the 90s or
the the 80s where Jack Kemp uh
congressman from Buffalo was famous for
his black Outreach um Richard Rearden
was the mayor of uh La back in the early
90s he did this um Steven Goldsmith in
Indianapolis was big on Outreach Chris
Christie in New Jersey uh went in Camden
other black communities for his
re-election and did extremely well with
a minority vote uh Haley barber in his
reelection Mississippi did very well
with black voters so I think um those
Republican politicians that are going to
take the time to go into these
neighborhoods and introduce themselves
and and giving a speech at the end of
ACP every four years is not black
Outreach
it's not that that is the NAACP blacks
are probably lost to the GOP you need to
go around the black leadership you need
to go into the neighborhoods into the
barber shops into the community centers
local businessmen and introduce yourself
because when you don't do that you allow
your opponent to paint you as a monster
and that's exactly what happens you need
to advertise on the black radio stations
Black websites black television shows
and so forth and you just don't you
don't see a lot of that going on in the
Republican party and I think that in
part explains why um you don't see a lot
of blacks voting
public thank
you